like i said she thought i had money she
thought i had money
she wanted a couple of tiffany
engagement rings so i said we can get
married you know i figured marriage
showed her that i love her sure it's
going to be all right
so i was like oh let's get married she's
like well i've always wanted a tiffany
ring [ __ ] i didn't have money to buy the
tiffany ring because all my money was
overseas so here i am i've defraud
counterfeit cashiers i
find a like a three carat ring on ebay
for 20 grand and uh
pay for it with a counterfeit cashier's
check
at the same time because she doesn't
want me to leave
she needs me there
typically if you're doing that type of
crime you need to be traveling
you can't do it in one central area
because you're going to be identified
pretty quickly
i knew that but i didn't have much
choice
so
start running counterfeit cashiers
checks to get the money to
to live and everything
and get the uh
get the engagement ring we were
scheduled to be married
our wedding date was february 26
2005.
february 8 2005
i'm
i've got a tiffany wedding band a couple
of them coming in
and i get arrested
in charleston south carolina
and
she didn't know
i told her i said i've got to go pick up
those rings she didn't she thought i was
just having them sent in
so i got to get those rings and i said
we'll go out to dinner after that and uh
i left at like eight o'clock in the
morning
and i was arrested at uh i think 11 30
something like that
of course i wanted to call her you know
and uh the fbi got me it turns out it
was it was controlled delivery there
were like 30 agents in the parking lot
fbi got me in charleston pd got me
within 45 minutes the secret service
comes in takes over that investigation
they knew exactly who they had
along about seven o'clock at night
they're like we want to search your
house
and i was like look i'll sign off on the
search if you let me go with you so i
can see her and uh
they were like okay so i got to see my
phone at that point i had like 140 calls
that she where she'd been trying to call
that time just way yeah
and uh
so they load me up in hell i mean you
talk about 10 12 cars
you know 40 agents
everything else she's got a dog at that
point i'm scared they want to shoot the
dog and uh
it was dark
and they had me walk up and they're all
behind me
i knock on the door and tell her the
police are there and she needs to put
the dog up
so she does and uh
they come in and just start ransacking
them put me in cuffs set me down start
berating her with questions she had no
idea what the hell was going on
were you able to say a word or two to
help her understand yeah i was trying to
tell her and at the same time they're
they take a watch off her wrist they let
her keep the ring uh
they're telling her i'm this guy what's
my real name bang bang bang bang bang
across across the board she's probably
terrified oh yeah yeah
yeah and uh i tell her i was like look
they're gonna reign me tomorrow don't
come
don't come i said i'll
see what's going on but don't show up of
course she's there next morning her dad
and she's she's back in the back crying
they're reading off the charges i'm
under 300 000
bond
everything else
and uh
that's it i
they throw me in a cell
meanwhile more charges keep coming in
you know
and uh
it's like 10 12 charges a day at that
point
and i'm trying to call her to make sure
she's all right and
just get through
so i spent three months in jail
and during that three months she visits
twice i get like three or four phone
calls to her
um
looking back now i understand why you
know back then it was like i'm the
victim you know why doesn't she talk to
me but
you know now i understand why
hell the girl loved me too you know and
then she found out i was this piece of
[ __ ] and uh
after a week in county jail
two agents fly in from new jersey two
secret service guys pulled me out of
cell
looked at me and they were like we got
your laptop and i was like yeah and uh
he's like well if you got anything on
your laptop i was like yeah he's like
you're gonna be charged for it that's
like i figured and then he looks at me
as like
can you do anything for us
and i told my exact words were look you
let me get back with elizabeth i'll do
whatever you want me to do
and he looks at me as like we're going
to get you out i was like all right so
they let me sit there for three months
to get a taste of it
and uh
get me out my sister they have the bond
reduced to a thousand dollars
my sister pays the thousand dollar bond
by this point she's disowned me and
because i'm dating the stripper
and
denise bonds me out
the person that i call
immediately
is elizabeth i'm out and uh she's like
i'll be there
so uh it's like 11 o'clock at night
i'm in the parking lot of the charleston
police charleston county jail
me and a secret service agent standing
there
and elizabeth had a friend that owned a
limo company so she pulls up in a limo
gets out pops the trunk
gets these two plastic containers out
that have my clothes in them
drops them off the pavement comes over
hugs me
call me later
gets in the car drives off
i'm sitting there crying like a baby
agent looks at me is that your fiance
i'm like yeah he's like i am so sorry
and i'm like yeah
i had
oh she sounds fascinating
yeah pull up in a limo
i had thirty dollars my name at that
point thirty dollars uh the agent had to
pay for my hotel room that first night
so he drops me off after paying for the
hotel room buy me something to eat
as soon as he drops me off i take that
thirty dollars
walk a half mile to walmart buy a
prepaid debit card so i can start back
in tax fraud
soon as i get back to the hotel room
call elizabeth beggar to come see me
she comes to see me and we talk most the
night
and uh
convince her to give me a chance i tell
her that
everything's gonna be all right they're
gonna hire me i'm gonna be this big
consultant
lies lies just so she get back with me
and uh
she's like okay and uh
so we moved from uh from charleston the
field office is in columbia south
carolina
and uh
i'm breaking the law
even before i start working with them
i'm breaking the law
and uh so they've got me in the office
the field offices they got this big war
room in there i'm on a laptop outside
line laptops hooked up to a 50-inch
plasma monitor on the wall
they've got
a desktop sitting directly next to me
outside line two secret service offices
officers in the room at all times with a
south carolina law enforcement officer
my job is four to six hours a day
surfing the web
picking up targets intel teaching them
how cyber crime operates everything else
like that
for the first two weeks
they are extremely diligent
they pay attention to everything that's
going on ask questions everything else
but the problem is is that
that [ __ ] gets boring
real quick
because i'm i'm very fast online doing
that
so they're they're like what the hell is
he doing and it gets tiring looking at a
guy just doing that [ __ ]
so after two weeks they get lazy and
bored and they start
watching porn
instead of watching me
at the same time they've got a key
logger
and they've got they've got spectre pro
and camtasia keyloggers and taking
snapshots of everything that i'm doing
go every night it goes on a dvd rom on a
spindle so i'm like
they're not going to go through that
[ __ ]
so i'm like [ __ ] it
start breaking all from inside secret
service offices while they're in the
room why not
that continues for 10 months
at the same time
the relationship with elizabeth fell
apart
completely fell apart
do you have an understanding of why it's
just because of the
her heart got broken because there was
lying it was the truth like she did a
lot yeah to uh sacrifice for the liberal
you've got uh
you got a woman there that uh
she had even said it she was like
she had told one of her friends we were
out having dinner one night
and this is before i got arrested she
told one of her friends and i was the
only guy
that ever asked her to stop using drugs
yeah
yeah
yeah i mean i i have to say that that
that part of the story is so
it's so powerful
and then that she chose to do it
and she chose to
stop
and she told me that uh
there was one instance she told me that
if she if she didn't marry me she'd
never be married and uh
as far as i know she's never been
married
and so it started to fall apart there
yeah
because
i was a piece of [ __ ]
still you didn't take a step by the way
can i just say
how just moving it is how honest you are
but yeah thank you thank you for being
that person
but at that time you
there's still that lying oh man yeah
yeah yeah so uh it's falling apart
she had
she wants to start going to strip clubs
and
i'm like [ __ ] it why not we'll go
so we start going to strip clubs and
she's you know she'll come back and get
wasted and we'll
have sex what have you and uh
one night
she looks at me and she was like uh
she was like i think it'd be funny
if you got a [ __ ] from somebody else
and uh
that got me
that got me i was like uh
to me that was the final straw right
there i was like
she doesn't care for me anymore or
anything else like that
we've been going to strip clubs
so i started dating another stripper and
uh she knew something was going on
and uh
she looks at me one day and she's like
why don't you just tell me that it's
over and i looked at her i said it's
over
we're done
and uh
i told her i was like look i said uh
whatever you want we were renting an
apartment i was like whatever you want
in here
take it
and uh
i said not only that but uh
i'll make sure you got money
for for several months so you're all
right
and uh i was like just leave me uh you
know leave my tv and leave
leave me some some plates and stuff
so i go to work that day
at the secret service come back that
night and she's taken everything
and left a picture of herself in the
bedroom on the floor i'm like
okay i guess i deserve that
so he's got i i i like her she's got
yeah she's cool she was cool
so
i i i'm giving her a thousand dollars
like every two weeks for some [ __ ] like
this and uh
it gets to the point because i'm doing
this tax fraud from inside the offices
well the debit card companies
are pinging the cards they start to
realize that hey some son of a [ __ ] is
stealing money using our debit card so
they start to shut down the cards before
i can pull cash out so i start not to
have the money to send to her and i'm
like
so i she calls and she's like look i
have to have money and i was like well
look i'm doing what i can
you promised money i was like look if
you knew what i was doing to get this
money you wouldn't be asking that
and she's like i need money my rent's
behind by a month right now and i'm like
your rent's behind she's like yeah so
i was like okay so i pick up the phone
call the rental office and i was like
i just want to make sure that uh you
know i'm sorry i'm behind on the rent
for this apartment number oh no that
rent's paid up three months
it's like okay hang up call elizabeth
back i was like you're behind on the
rent and she was like yeah and i was
like
funny they just said you're up on it
three months and she gets quiet and
she's like
well you lied to me too
and i was like
you're right
i did i did that
i was like but look i i can't do it
anymore and uh
that's the last time i spoke to her
right there
what happens is
i was breaking law from inside the
offices
i had a buddy
that his name was sean mims out of los
angeles i had taught him how to do tax
return fraud
i told sean i go missing right i go
missing for three months i told him if i
ever went missing not to contact me
and
so i go missing then i show back up
online
first day he contacts so he becomes a
target and they identify him pretty
quickly at that point he's set to be
arrested sometime in march of uh
of six that's when he's said to be
arrested
operation rolling stone was the name of
the operation nine people were supposed
to be arrested that night
so secret service
goes in a re goes and arrests this guy
they search his apartment and don't find
anything
the apartment manager comes out and
explains to him how sean has done all
kinds of work to the apartment as a
matter of fact he brought in 30 thousand
dollars worth of italian tile to put in
the apartment that he's renting and by
the way last night he had a u-haul out
here and took out a whole shitload of
stuff
secret service comes back in
they look at me and they're like we need
you to take a polygraph
and my answer was
i ain't taking a polygraph
so they're like well we'll throw you
back in jail if you don't i was like
call my lawyer lawyer gets me on the
phone he's like
you don't have to take the polygraph i
was like well good i'm not going to he's
like but they will throw you back in
jail i was like don't want to do that
he's like
have you done anything i was like
yeah and he's like
well you can try to pass the polygraph
i'm like okay
so i
was like let's take the polygraph
they asked three questions the questions
were
have you talked to anybody
have you have you been on computer
outside of the offices have you talked
to the press which i was interviewing
with a new york times writer the entire
time and then have you contacted or
warned anybody about investigations and
i failed polygraph completely
so they revoked the bond
take me back down to charleston county
throw me into jail
three days later
secret service shows back up
and uh pulled me out of the cell it's
jim ramichon and bobby kirby and they
were i mean honestly i i
they were good men
and they gave me chances upon chances to
do the right thing and
i was not ready to do that and uh
jim ramacone and bobby's in there and
bobby i mean bobby was a friend i mean
truly was i later on a couple years ago
i had a chance to uh
a couple years ago i had a chance to uh
to have lunch with a man and uh
i told him i was sorry for everything i
did to him because i got him and him and
another agent fired
and uh
i told him i was sorry for what happened
and uh
he told me then he's like we were your
friends man we were truly your friends
so they were good they wanted to help
yeah
they weren't they wanted you to be a
good man yeah yeah and what what got me
so damn bad is uh
i told him i was like man i'm trying to
be a better guy yeah and uh he's like
brett you always were a good guy you
just didn't know it
you